Gentlemen, it is my special pleasure to introduce a woman who clearly needs no introduction.
A very great actress on her first trip to London.
Marilyn, is it true that you wear nothing in bed but perfume?
Darling, as I'm in England, let's say I sleep in nothing but Yardley's lavender.
I long to see her.
This story describes a miracle.
Ms. Monroe?
Marilyn is not ready.
Excuse my horrible face.
Few days of my life when a dream came true.
Are you frightened of me, Colin?
No!
Good. 'Cause I like you.
Colin, is everything okay?
Ms. Monroe had some large packages she needed handled.
What's Marilyn doing with my third assistant?
Surprise!
Get back here, Colin!
I have something in my eye.
I can't see anything.
Be careful not to get in too deep, son.
Marilyn Monroe fancying you? Come on!
She breaks hearts, she will break yours.
I wouldn't buy that little girl lost act, if I were you.
I think Marilyn knows exactly what she's doing.
All people will ever see is Marilyn Monroe.
What must it be like to be the most famous woman on Earth?
You could quit this. Forget Marilyn Monroe.
Forget Hollywood.
Let it all go.
First love is such sweet despair, Colin.
Shall I be her?
Who?
Marilyn.